one of the busiest times of the year we
know it's here also a big time for
families to come together yeah we talked
to some Travelers at the airport at Reid
International today who are reuniting
with their loved ones for the holiday
[Music]
funny how this all looks different but
it feels the same we've got about 22
people for Thanksgiving it's my
brother's birthday and Thanksgiving so
we've got all of that all of our family
coming out there's nothing more
important than family so any opportunity
to get together we truly uh enjoy it we
try to get together here every year for
Thanksgiving to get the family together
for a good celebration for something
something positive
my daughter's coming home from her
Mormon mission for LDS mission for two
years to Argentina the timing was just
lucky the day before Thanksgiving so
we've got a lot to be thankful for today
we actually have my whole family here
for the first time in a few years so
I've got six kids and so we're all here
today to meet her as she comes off the
plane oh you see a missionary two years
is a long time she loves to help me cook
Thanksgiving dinner there's some people
over there too there she is is that her
no no no what flight is she on welcome
home it was about 24 hours of traveling
this last year I spent teaching people
about how important the family is how
important it is to be able to have this
closest to have the support now I get to
come and spend this with my family and
they're the most important people in
here make dinner tomorrow and and watch
some sports
[Music]
that is so sweet and they haven't seen
her in two years that she's been on that
mission in Argentina that's beautiful
good stuff thanks Henry Takaya
photojours who put that together